[MUSIC]
Hi everybody.
Thanks a lot for coming.
I just got back.
I spent I think it was this last weekend
at my own 25th business school reunion in
New Haven.
And hope you're enjoying it as much as we
did, as much as we enjoyed ours.
I always find it very interesting.
I don't know how long this lasts but
at the 25th reunion it's still true that
half the people look like it
was last week and nothing has happened to
them in the middle.
And, the other half you say, really?
[LAUGH] And, then you say, oh no, you
haven't changed a bit, when you recover.
[LAUGH] So I wanna talk to you about a
little bit
about the economics underlying this book I
wrote about which is called,
Everything I Ever Needed to Know About
Economics, I Learned From Online Dating.
And, basically, that's kind of a cheap
title to get people's attention.
Because the book has a little bit about
online dating, but
a lot about other contexts.
And I'll, I'll talk some about online
dating.
But everything I say here can be put in
the job market context just as well,
because I have to be honest I didn't
actually learn
everything I do know about economics from
online dating.
I knew most of it from graduate school and
from being a labor economist.
So I'm a labor economist and, the, the
labor market.
Is very similar to the market for
significant others or romantic partners,
and I know you have to be an economist to
use that last phrase, but this is
kind of the way we think about it, what I
like about thinking about the economics,
using dating or the marriage market, what
I really like about it is two things.
One is people are interested in this
market, of course.
So that's nice.
The other thing is, when people think
about economics, they think about money.
Economists don't care at all about money.
We're, well, I take that back.
There are some macroeconomists.
There are some macro economists who have
to worry about money supply and
things like that, but most economists and
certainly pretty much all
micro economists, money is just a
convenience for transacting.
We're not inherently interested in money
at all.
Remember, economics is the study of scarce
resources, and
in online dating that's an appropriate
place to think about that, because there
are a lot of scarce recourses that we will
go through as we talk about this.
So that's kind of what got me interested
in doing this, and then any chance I get
to teach people some economics in a way
that doesn't feel that much as like I'm
doing that, and with limited mathematics,
is always, is always fun for me.
So let's talk about that.
So what I'm gonna do is take you through
this in four steps.
I'm not sure we'll get through all four
steps.
But basically you can think about there
being four stages in a relationship.
And, again, the job market context works
very well here.
So I can just change some of the
terminology here, and
I can say the economics of jobs in four
stages.
So there's choosing your market.
That's true whether you're talking about
jobs or, or dating.
There's creating your profile, which in
the job context would be
putting together a resume and your
LinkedIn profile and the like, but
in the dating world it's putting up your
online profile.
There's the first date, or the job
interview, you could think of it as.
And then there's settling down.
There's picking the job, or picking your
mate, and that's where I want to go.
So these, these all relate to one or two
different chapters of my book.
Between this you can sort of cover six of
the ten chapters.
And I think from an economist's
perspective,
the thing I like about breaking it down
into these four segments is each of these
four ideas won somebody a Nobel Prize in
economics somewhere along the way.
And so we'll talk about those examples and
the contributions thereof as we go.
So stage one is thinking about what market
you wanna get into, and basically,
when you look at markets, bigger is
better, that's a general rule.
Now there can be problems with finding a
right match once you're in the big market,
but if you'll indulge me I'll just give
you a sense for how that plays out.
I'm just gonna read a couple of paragraphs
from the book that explain how
that plays out in an online dating.
This is chapter six of the book.
I said as an experiment I logged into
match.com and
got a list of the women between 40 and 50
who lived within ten miles of me.
I was presented with 454 women.
I did the same thing on date.com and I was
given 134 women to choose from.
Does it matter which site I use?
It seems like both have plenty of options
for me.
Now consider a third option.
I play a lot of tennis.
It would be nice to meet a woman who
shared this interest, so
I logged in to tennisdate.com and searched
for all women between 40 and
50 years old who live in California.
I was presented with 52 options, 9 of whom
were within a 1 hour drive of my house.
That's a much smaller set to choose from,
but
at least they all share an interest of
mine.
I also pretended to be a vegetarian.
[LAUGH] I am not.
But I'm willing to imagine for
a few minutes, although I would draw the
line at pretending to be vegan.
There were 22 women between 40 and
50 living when, within 20 miles of me on
veggiedate.com.
[LAUGH] You, you might think I'm making
this stuff up, but I'm not.
Any, any term you want, put it into your,
the URL at the top of your screen and
then put date.com at the end of it and you
will find, you will find a dating site.
So, finally, what if I try to meet women
in person instead of over the internet?
Living in an area with a lot of well
educated people,
I am lucky to live near a couple of high
quality book stores.
Each of those hosts a book club.
Where patrons can meet to discuss a work
of fiction.
Now, I'll admit that I've never been to
one of these clubs, so I can't make any
statements about their demographic
composition with absolute certainty, but
I would bet that the vast majority of
people who attend the meetings are female.
I'd bet too, I, that if I went to one of
these meeting I's be the only man there,
and would meet about five women who were
my age and single.
So, what I wanna talk about now is, which
option is best?
Match.com, date.com, tennisdate.com, or
the book club?
And the, the basic principle is,
match.com.
Or, you know, I don't wanna do
advertisements for them.
The largest site you can get, you can get,
because all else equal,
bigger markets are better.
Now that's a general principle in
economics.
It doesn't, it's not limited to online
dating or the job market, so for example.
Financial markets we want big markets,
why because we want more information
acquisition.
We want, we want the allocation of
resources to be most efficient.
We want everybody to come together, and
allocate the resources efficiently.
And get the information fed through the
market.
Also, more price competition.
So, you know?
A big bazaar with lots of people selling
jewelry, is gonna be more efficient than
individual jewelry stores, where people
can sort of take advantage of you.
So more efficient aggregation of
information, more price competition,
the same exact principle applies to dating
sites and to the job market.
But there's a huge difference, there's a
very different reason for why that is.
And that's because, as economists, I think
about the market for
matching to romantic partners as one of
differentiated goods.
So potential mates for me are
differentiated goods, okay?
And if you say that out loud, the market
for you goes away very quickly, but,
[LAUGH] but nonetheless, that's the way,
that's the way to think about it.
And so, no two jobs, and no two life
partners are the same.
You're talking about a group of,
you know, every barrel of oil is pretty
much the same.
Every box of cereal is, you know, there
are many that are the same, and
then there are subtle differences across
brands and so forth.
So what we want is a thick market in, in
life partners and in the job market, why?
Not because of that price competition
effect, because we wanna find people.
We wanna be able to put together the best
possible matches.
So, it's not that I just want a life
partner, I want one who's good for
me and for whom I am good in return.
So, how do we go about thinking about
that?
Why does big marke, why are big markets
better for that sort of thing, well
let me show, let me, let me in, introduce
a metaphor here to make the point.
So think their, think about this stage
here as being the boardwalk.
And I'm in the middle and
just think of people being spread out
along the boardwalk and the people
who are closest to me on that boardwalk
are very good matches for me.
And the people at one end of the boardwalk
are, you know, think of Goldilocks.
They're, one end of the boardwalk they're
too big,
at the other end they're too small.
Some differentiator along which you can
think about that.
So where do I wanna look for a significant
other?
Do I wanna look on the Santa Monica Pier
which is teaming with people.
And every you know, if I'm in the middle
of the pier and
there's a bunch of people around me
metaphorically who are very similar to me.
Do I want that?
Or do I wanna go to this boardwalk and
look for a life partner?
Well, I wanna go to this one, not for the
price competition, but
because here's more people around who are
very similar to me.
So what we want to.
What you can think about is the left.
The Santa Monica Pier is Match.com and
the smaller pier is Date.com, the one that
had many fewer people on it, and
it's going to be harder for me not to find
a match, because there is people on it,
but to find one who is very close to, who
is as close to my interests.
The more you pack the boardwalk, the more
packed we are, our interests are.
We're gonna have a problem if the
boardwalk's too packed.
How do we match the right people to the
right places.
That, we need a good algorithm for that,
but for now, don't worry about that.
The left, you can also think of the left
one as monster.com for job boards.
And you can think of the right one as the
Palo Alto classifieds.
Right?
Very, very few jobs out there.
Not much you can do.
Oh sorry, one other way of thinking about
this is, the left boardwalk would be
the MLS listing service for houses, the
right boardwalk.
Would be whatever listings your realtor
that you're using happens to have for
sale at a given moment.
And what do you wanna go to?
You wanna go to the bigger market.
That's kind of obvious, I guess.
So now, what about these niche sites that
I talked about?
Why doesn't tennisdate.com work?
It might, it's probably doesn't.
And the reason is, what you wanna think
about is all of those sites,
farmersonly.com is the one exception where
I've been wrong.
Farmersonly.com is extremely successful.
I would've bet heavily against them in the
initial dates, but
I guess that's, turns out to be a thicker
market than I thought.
But tennisdate and veggiedate.com and
Farmers Only.
They would seem like they would give you
the best of both worlds, right?
You potentially are limiting yourself to
people on the boardwalk who are exactly,
have those interests.
You're cutting off a slice of the
boardwalk,
which is the right set of people for you.
So that would seem like it might work.
However, that's only gonna work if the,
if these sites slice the boardwalk so that
they keep all the people around you.
Rather than just keeping the people,
rather than just slicing the boardwalk, so
that they people who are with you.
Are near you on the boardwalk, they have
to do a little better job than that.
They have to slice the boardwalk so
everybody wants to go with you.
What do I mean by that?
Well, what I mean by that is, these are
gonna,
these niche sites are gonna be great if
there are a lot of people in that niche.
If the niche is a thick market in and of
itself.
Vegetarians are not a thick enough market.
At least in smaller cities, for them to
create a thick market where everybody can
just limit themselves on that one
dimension.
Tennis is another thing along those lines.
So it has to be the case that this niche
is basically a dealbreaker.
So you want it to be the case not that
there's a lot, not.
This whole boardwalk thing, the key is, if
you're gonna have a niche site,
it has to be the case that everybody near
you on that boardwalk, is in that niche.
Otherwise, it's not gonna work.
So, tennis is a nice thing.
But I don't really care if my partner, I
mean, I want,
it would be great if she played tennis,
but it's not a deal breaker for me.
And as a result,
I'm slicing off a lot of people who would
otherwise be near me on the boardwalk,
if I limited myself to tennisdate.com or
veggiedate.com or whatever.
So, which sites are gonna make it?
Which niche sites, and we'll come back to
this,
this all applies to the job market just as
well, which niche sites are gonna make it?
Well, here's one that I don't have good
hopes for [LAUGH] glutenfreesingles.com.
It exits.
People are on it.
And I'm sure if you're really into gluten
free, maybe this is a good thing, but
it just seems to me you're cutting a lot
of people who are near you on
the boardwalk off if you limit yourself to
gluten free people.
Okay, you must love dogs dating.
I tried some of these sites, cuz I have a
dog.
I love my dog, and it's great.
You know, and I ended up with a girlfriend
who has a dog and we, it's all nice bec,
because we're both really happy about
walking our dogs and things.
But I never would have limited myself,
because a lot of the people who were near
me on the boardwalk didn't love dogs or
at least not enough to limit themselves to
that site.
Okay?
So, that the general principle to take
away here is, these sites aren't
gonna make it, because they eliminate too
many people that are close to you on
the boardwalk, there's a lot of people who
don't limit themselves
to dogs who were near me on the boardwalk
and I didn't want to eliminate them.
Now, which niche sites are working?
Actually there's a couple of areas where
these sites are working very well.
One of them is religion, religious
oriented sites.
Christianmingle.com, very successful.
Why?
Because everybody who you would consider
dating if
you're a serious Christian is also a
serious Christian.
It's not like vegans, it's not like gluten
free,
this is a group where everyone near you on
the boardwalk is in this niche, so we
can limit ourselves to that, have our own
thick market for just Christians, the LDS
dating site is also quite successful, some
of the ones that are focused on.
Certain racial groups that want to focus,
stay, stay within themselves.
Those have been successful.
So this, where there's a big enough site.
Another one that's very successful is
ourtime.com.
If any of you are at like your 40th
reunion or
later and you're single, this might be a
site for you.
It's one of the older dating, it's, it's
one of the niche sites for
older dating, okay?
And so these types of sites are gonna be
more successful than
glutenfree.com and so forth, because
everyone near me on
the boardwalk is also potentially
interested in this site.
So if we're gonna break off and
have these niche sites, we need to have a
thick market in and of itself for that.
So now these same exact ideas apply to
online job sites.
Monster.com is a great place to go looking
for
people and a great place to go looking for
jobs.
It's a very thick market, and so forth.
LinkedIn is another, for certain types of
jobs,
has become the go to place because it's so
big and so forth.
But there are job sites that are
specialized, that have been
very successful as well because everybody
in a certain market goes to them.
So I interviewed for a different project,
I interviewed a company called CollegeFrog
in Florida.
They have monster.com equivalent idea, but
it's focused on just people coming
out of undergraduate accounting programs,
because these people are coming out and
everybody is looking for the same type of
job and everybody's looking for the same
types of people, and so specializing that
site is like focusing on the piece
of the boardwalk where all of job hunters
wanna be at that point in their life.
Later on the specialized needs vary.
So what does this tell us?
Well as a labor economist,
thick market, the implications of this are
very important.
It's quite, now about to quote you
research from various
research findings from various people.
One is, if you go to a metropolitan area
that's relatively big you're going to find
all else equal that the young people job,
hop around the jobs, hop, job hop more.
Why?
Because think about the boardwalk as being
all the potential jobs for them.
If the boardwalk is more filled in it's
worth moving a little further up and
down, and trial and error until you find
exactly the right place for yourself.
Right?
So the bigger markets that, but once
you're older what you
find is a New York City versus an, you
know, a, what's a smaller city?
In New York City versus Portland, you're
gonna find that people job hop more
when they're young and then they stay in
their jobs longest when they're older.
Why?
Because once you've found that right place
on the boardwalk for
yourself, you're that much happier
compared to all the other alternatives.
Whereas the sparsely held, the sparse
boardwalk, you know,
you keep moving around because you haven't
found exactly the right spot.
So these things you see in the data, in
big, in big Metropolitan areas,
people job hop more when they're young and
less when they're old.
By the same token, doctors and lawyers are
more specialized in bigger markets.
So if you wanted to go, if you lived in
Topeka, Kansas, let me, try even a smaller
city, if you lived in a smaller city in
Kansas, I don't know, Liberal, Kansas.
I've been to this place, it has about
20,000 people.
If you live in Liberal, Kansas and you get
arrested, or you wanna get divorced or
you wanna buy a house, you would call the
same lawyer for all of those things.
Because the market is, there's not that
many lawyers along the boardwalk and so
they all have to do a bunch of stuff.
But if you even go to Topeka which is
bigger but not a big place, for
any of those three things you would call a
specialized lawyer.
So when we have these markets that are
more special, bigger
specialization spreads out, or another way
of saying that is, here in Paolo Alto,
our doctors are very specialized, whereas
if you go back to Liberal, Kansas,
you are gonna find just a few doctors who
are very much doing general practice and
if you are really sick, they are gonna
send you off to a bigger,
more specialized market.
Outsourcing is easier as well, but I won't
get into that as much.
So, what, what are some other applications
of this idea of thick markets?
Thick markets are really an important idea
in so many businesses.
Right?
If you're gonna start if,
if you're a member of the Class of 2008 or
later,
you are by definition trying to start some
sort of social media company right now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's, I don't know if you've heard
that.
That's the new rule here at Stanford.
And these are people who have to thick,
think constantly about how can we create
the thickest possible market.
That's what that's all about.
So, a couple of examples of how that plays
out in
the business world is this is the Mall of
America in Minnesota.
It's the biggest mall in the world.
Where would you rather be if you needed a
pair of jeans?
Walking down some random street in Kansas
or the Mall of America?
For some reasons you might rather be in
Kansas cuz the Mall of America has,
you know, probably isn't that fun for some
people.
But if all you care about is the selection
of jeans,
you obviously wanna be at the Mall of
America.
So malls and these other places spring up
because they wanna create thick markets
which allow people to be very, to get what
they want, to match well to their needs.
This is the Bowery at Lower Manhattan.
I don't know how many of you have ever
been down to
the Bowery in Lower Manhattan.
It was kind of a down and out part of New
York for many years, but
it had one thing it was very well known
for, it had the lighting district.
So I don't know if you have ever been to,
anybody's been there, but
back in the 80's when I lived in New York
City,
you'd walk down the street to the Bowery
and it was just incredible.
There'd be one light store next to the
next.
There was like, blocks of stores that sold
lights.
Now this was strictly a thick market sort
of effect.
These stores, think about your self.
You're opening a lighting store, and
you say okay, do I wanna open it in the
lighting district or
up on the upper east side where there's no
other lighting stores around.
Well you're tempted to say, I want it on
the upper east side, and then, you know,
you don't have as much competition, and
you might end up doing that.
But on the other hand you can see saying,
hey wait a minute,
I'm gonna open in the lighting district
because everybody knows when they need
lights they go to the lighting district
cuz that's where the market is thick.
And they go from store to store until they
find exactly what they need.
So as a result, this, this became a very
thick market for lighting.
Now, the lighting district is more or less
a shell of what it used to be.
And what happened is there was a very
thick market and
it all worked very nicely.
People went there to shop for lights.
And then there was a technical change and
nobody needed to go to the lighting
district anymore cuz now you
could just sit in your home and do
everything on the Internet.
So the thick market moved from the
lighting district into the Internet and
we know, so a lot of these a lot of these
physical spaces that were very specialized
in creating a thick market have been sort
of ser, replaced by the fact that you,
if it, if it can be put on the Internet,
it saves everybody the trouble of going
down to that part of New York.
This is a factory making carpeting in
Dalton, Georgia.
Dalton, Georgia is the carpet capital of
the world.
Until recently, it made more than 90% of
the carpet made in the entire world was
made in Dalton, Georgia.
Why was that?
It was a total historical accident.
There was some woman, who had a very
successful tufted quilt business there.
Back about 100 years ago, I don't,
I forget the dating, the timing of all
this now.
So you know these quilts that kind of have
the,
the threads come up through the bottom,
and you can make these nice tufted quilt.
She had a pretty successful business set
up which had grown and
she had a lot of subcontractors that
provided the parts.
Well it turned out carpeting is made more
or less the way she made her quilts, and
so when people started making carpeting
they said okay, I wanna make my carpets.
I'm gonna go ahead and set this business
up in Dalton,
Georgia because look there's all these
people that know how to supply me already.
And then everybody who wanted to supply
the carpet manufacturers started moving
to Dalton.
And so these thick markets reinforced
themselves where we
ended up with everybody down in Dalton,
Georgia.
Now foreign competition is finally making
Dalton no
longer the carpet capital of the world to
the degree it once was, but
it's still very much the focus of carpet
manufacturing.
And, by the way, the same story explains
why cars are made in Detroit.
Henry Ford put his business there because
people had made carriages,
the subcontractors to carriage makers were
in Detroit and
he figured this would be a good way to do
it.
So again these thick markets develop for
various reasons and in various markets and
you wanna be in them,
they are a much better place to, to
operate than sort of all by yourself.
Okay, so, I'm gonna just kind of skip
through most of stage 2.
Stage 2 is presenting yourself, how do you
write your resume and that sort of thing.
And the main, the main point I am gonna
make here,
an I am gonna skip the details are.
That if you're not very careful and you
have to think about his on your resume and
on your dating profile, what you say is
very important.
What you don't say is equally important.
And the economists' version of this is a
term called statistical discrimination.
If I see that you have some characteristic
and you don't, and
you are silent about some other
characteristic,
I might statistically put these two things
together.
So in the, in the context of online
dating,
when I was out looking, when I started
dating again, I,
on my profile said that I was separated
because my divorce wasn't final.
Big problem, it turns out.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I did not see this coming.
I was totally naive about that.
I was, you know, I wrote my profile, I'm
recently separated, I'm so
excited to, and everybody sees this and of
course,
there are three types of people who are
separated.
There are people like myself who are,
like, nice guys ready to give
it another try and really ready to jump in
and make somebody very happy.
There are emotional wrecks who can do
nothing but
think about their failed relationship.
And there are guys who are seeing if
there's something better out there and
may go back to their wife.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's very hard to tell people I am a
type one.
They assume you're not until your divorce
is final and
then you can move on with your life.
Well by the same token in the job market,
so, for me this wasn't a big deal,
you know like, in this, in the world of
statistical discrimination,
even I have no sympathy for the story I
just told you.
But there are many cases where this idea
is a much bigger problem.
For car insurance is one.
Hiring young women is probably one that
you've, and racial profiling are probably
the two biggest examples
of the exact same idea I just talked about
with much bigger social implications.
So if you're hiring, if you're hiring for
a position of a new Stanford MBA, and
you have a 27 year old man and a 27 year
old woman with very similar resumes,
you can't help but look ahead and say,
okay, wait a minute.
Statistically, the man is more likely to
stay in the workforce than the woman is.
That's just a true fact.
That's not being prejudiced or anything
like that.
And so we have laws and so forth to take
care of that sort of thing.
Racial profiling is the same thing of
course.
You know, all this talk of,
African Americans are much more likely to
be pulled over than,
Caucasians when driving, that's just
strictly statistical discrimination.
The assumption is that African Americans,
whose crime rate is higher,
are more likely to commit a crime and
we're gonna be more careful about that.
Well, this has certain social problems,
leads to certain social problems and
what, now that we've decided to sort, sort
of address that through laws and so forth.
So the main point of this isn't so much
trying address those social problems which
are beyond the scope of my ability fo fix
those problems but to remind you that,
you know, in, in setting up your online
profile, be it for jobs or
for, for work, or whatever, you have to be
very careful what you say, because people
make assumptions about information that
you leave off, and they do it based on,
on statistical relationships between what
you have told them and what you leave off.
I'm gonna skip this general, the general
idea I'm getting at
here is what's known to economists as
adverse selection, and
it won the Nobel Prize for a guy named
George Akerlof.
But I'm gonna skip that and
I'm even gonna skip explaining why you
should be scared of Volvo drivers,-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Anybody wants to talk about Volvo
drivers, we can do that afterwards.
So what I do wanna spend a little bit of
time on is step three, cuz again,
very relevant to the job market as well as
the, dating market.
And let me just give you a quick idea of
how people lie on dating sites.
So I'm gonna, I'm just quoting a couple of
studies here.
A couple of, I didn't lie of course but
I'm told others do.
So once, one academic study found that
most men exaggerated their height,
most people of both gender understated
their weight,
and about one fifth of people lied about
their age.
And OkCupid, which is a large dating site,
started, I might add,
by a member of the Stanford GSB class of
2004.
Their blog, they keep, they occasionally
will post some information about what's
happening on their site.
And they found that the, the average
heights claimed by men on their profiles,
are suspiciously greater than the average
height of American men.
And that there are an inexplicable number
of men who claim to
be exactly six feet tall.
Similarly they found that the incomes
claimed on the site are suspicious,
are equally suspicious.
There are four times as many people making
$100,000 per year as there should be.
And finally they found that people often
posted data pictures that
likely made them look more attractive than
they really were.
More specifically, they reached the very
scientific finding that, quote,
hotter photos were much more likely to be
outdated than normal ones.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay?
You can only use the term hotter if
you're a professor as long as you're
quoting someone else, that's the-
So, so, as an economist, I look at that
and I say, well of course people lie.
People have incentives to lie, they are
maximizing their utility,
they are thinking carefully about
strategically lying.
Lance Armstrong lied for ten plus years.
He tried to mix himself in with the other
guys who were racing without taking drugs.
Actually I don't think there were any of
those guys but he was a-
>> [LAUGH].
>> If they existed he was hoping to be
mistaken for one of those people, and so
as a result.
That's, that's a very rational world we
live in you,
you can be very rational online.
Now there's a whole other side of lying,
which we as economists can explain.
And it is very important in online dating,
it's it goes beyond the purview
of economists and that's people lying to
themselves.
So you might put on you, so the types of
things like height and
income, we know that has to, you know,
people know their heights and incomes.
But on, on dating profiles,
people will say things like, I'm a very
positive person.
And, you know, you meet the person and you
say.
That's not quite true, and that's, that's
not something I, as an economist,
can explain because that person is likely
to be lying to themselves.
Okay?
And, you know, feel free to find the women
and ask what I lied about, and
not to mention when I was on online
dating, I'm sure there's a lot of,
of non economics are played out there as
well.
So but the main point is people discount
what others say, knowing people are lying,
so and this plays out exactly in the job
market.
People pad their resumes, and
when I look at a resume I'm skeptical of
what I see as a result.
And that, that's very problematic and sad,
why?
Because, if you wanna be a very honest
person,
you almost can't be, because everybody
else is competing for
that same woman, man, job, whatever it is,
is not everyone, but
many people are exaggerating or lying, an
you're put in this difficult position.
And as a result,
you discount what other people say,
despite the fact that you know,
some of them are telling the truth and
that's, so that's all very unfortunate.
So how do we fix these problems?
Well, one thing is verification, and in
the online dating context,
that's problematic, but it's,
I think it's moving along more in foreign
countries than in the US.
So in China and South Korea there are
dating sites, where you have to where they
verify certain information with government
documents.
So you send in your driver's license,
which tells them your height and your wait
and things like that.
Or you send in your, I don't know if, you
know, something your way,
your paycheck to verify your income and
things like that.
So that's good, but as businesspeople,
you're, you might already be thinking
ahead and realize, that changes the nature
of your dating site's business model.
From a very fixed cost thing where you
just set up the site and
the users take care of everything
themselves, to a much more variable cost
thing, where I now have to have somebody
verify your height and weight and
do all these things that are time
consuming and expensive.
So we haven't seen anybody cra, crack that
nut, so to speak, here in the US yet.
In a few foreign countries, where labor
costs are cheaper,
they have been able to go a little bit
more in that direction.
There is, however, some hope, as long as
you are a woman, in the US,
there is a site called Onlulu.com, where
you can go and review men.
[LAUGH] It's just like Amazon Reviews,
only very different I guess.
[LAUGH] I don't know, I have never seen
any of these reviews because the site,
you're not allowed, you have to log in
through Facebook,
and so it knows your gender and you can't
go on if you're male.
So, that's one avenue to go through, but
at the second one,
where I wanna spend more time, partially
because it's so interesting from
an economics point of view and partially
because of the GSB relationship here,
is the economic concept of signaling.
And this is what won our former dean
Michael Spence,
the Nobel Prize in economics.
The idea is very simple, it's just, you
need to, when you can't verify,
if you can't walk around with a sign that
says I really do make this money and
it somehow could be verified, if in the
absence of being able to do that,
you wanna think of other ways to separate
yourself from the liars, from the fakers.
Not necessarily, yeah, liars, fakers,
whatever you want to call it.
In order for a signal to work, it has to
have two qualities.
It has to be the case that it's correlated
with whether or
not you're really the type of person who's
qualified for something,
and I'll show you that in an example in a
second.
And, it has to be costly for you to
signal.
And it has to be specifically less costly
for the qualified people, than for
the unqualified people.
Otherwise the system breaks down, and
the Lance Armstrongs can mix with everyone
else or the,
you know, lying, cheating guys on websites
can mix with everybody else.
So the way Spence set this up,
forget about, now back to the job market
for a minute.
The way Spence wrote this model some 40
years ago now, was he
started from the following assumption,
which is a little bit troubling,
given he used to be the dean here at the
business school.
He started from the assumption that school
was a total waste of time,
you learn nothing in school.
I was kinda hoping for a few [LAUGH]
that's sounds ridiculous.
But having gone here and getting more
agreement,
having I see I'm getting more agreement
than I was hoping for.
So, the good students the assumption here
is that the good students
are qualified for good jobs, and people
who would be bad students.
Would not be good in those good jobs and
so
we make people go to school, not because
we wanna separate.
Not because they learn anything, but
because it helps us separate the good
people from the less.
Let me rephrase that,
it separates the more able workers, from
the less able workers.
And so, as a result if the equilibrium
works out nicely,
people who know they're not able don't
even bother going to school,
because it's not worth the costs to them
and we get this nice separation.
Well how does that work in other contexts?
Well let's talk about it in dating for a
second.
There are two problems in dating.
Two different kinds of problems.
One is if I go to a dating site, I can
send a message at very low cost to
a woman and say I wanna meet you, you
look,your profile looks great.
So how do we get around that?
How do we make it a little more costly for
you?
And make it a little more meaningful when
you say I want,
to meet you rather than 100, sending 100
similar messages.
Well one is you can, the way I solved this
problem was, I would send fewer messages,
but personalize them more.
So I would make sure I looked in the
profile, and
I'd say I like that same show on NPR.
I, you know, like the picture of your dog
and so forth, things like that,
and that allows peop, you know if you get
a message like that and it says,
hey let's meet for coffee, you know,
hopefully that has some of an impression.
Well it turns out there's a Korean dating
site that took this a step further, and
helped people separate themselves from
those who were just average guys out for,
you know, to meet any, anybody they could
meet.
They proposed a system of virtual roses,
and the way this system worked is,
they said during a period of time, anybody
on
the site can send as many I wanna meet
you, or other messages as they wanted.
But in addition, over a period of time,
they were allowed two, exactly two,
virtual roses.
And these were basically saying, I really
wanna meet you.
Okay?
I, you're one of my, you're one of the two
people I most wanna meet.
Now, remember the two properties of a
signal.
It's costly because, in this case, you
only have two of them.
So, the opportunity cost of using your
signal was very high.
And the second thing is, it separates you
from those who don't.
Who does, its, its, its sep, it's qual,
I'm sorry it's correlated with whether or
not you really want to meet that person
because of course you're going to
use your rose on the people, and as a
result, this particular thing
helped make better matches in the Korean
market in which it was used.
Now there are problems, this hasn't rolled
out more generally because there are ways
of gaining that system once it becomes
part of the thing.
You can have multiple profiles.
You can do other sorts of things that
would ruin it.
But at least if you can figure out a way
to get the signalling thing down,
it seems like it can help make better
matches.
Example number two is, if I wanna say I
make a lot of money, so
I'm sorry, crass fact, the data backed me
up on this, I'm not mak, I'm not
statistically discriminating I'm just
telling you the data are true on this.
Men are attracted to good-looking women.
Women are attracted to men who make money.
Sad, but true, so how do I say I make a
lot of money, when anybody can say that?
How do I make it true?
So it's only self-reporting and so
forth so, you know, you can think about
sort of ways of wasting a lot of money to
sort of show somebody I care about I
really have a lot of money.
One option I've always thought about, and
no dating site has taken me up on this,
is charge people x dollars, maybe $1 or $5
to send a message saying,
I wanna meet you, and in the process
choose a charity that that money goes to.
And that not only signals I really wanna
meet you cuz I just spent that money, but
it also shows you which charity I'm
interested in.
So if I get a message from a woman that
says, you know, who have to pay $5.00,
and she chose to send her money to Planned
Parenthood, and another one, from someone
who sent their money to the NRA, we have
sort of, we have made some money for
some organizations and we have also
learned a lot about people along the way.
Another solution,
we like as economist to think of very
rational people as being very rational.
But one of the all time great irrational
but
rational economic moments was from the
movie The Dark Knight,
where the eh, Joker, played by Heath
Ledger, signaled to the mob.
I am in this for things other than the
money,
by burning a big pile of the money that
they had made and stolen.
So, you know, an alternative, if it
weren't for
the fact that you'd look like a crazy
person, would be to on the first date,
put down $1,000 and light it on fire.
And that would in fact show people, that
you are very wealthy.
Nobody's taken me up on that one either,
and I think that's just as well both for
second hand smoke reasons and issues that
would come up.
There are many other applications of
signaling,
I'm gonna skip ahead to the very last
point real quickly, so
I leave a little time left for some
discussion.
My favorite is called, maybe is college
applications.
Early decisions are just a form of
signalling.
You have one signal,
it's expensive because you only get to
apply early to one place.
Okay?
And
so, that's what early admissions eh, is
basically all about.
And there's a nice paper, by a couple of
economists one of whom is John Levin in
the economics department here.
Showing the importance of early decisions
as a means of signalling and
how schools take it very seriously.
Okay, so those are a few other examples
that I,
I'm gonna not talk about right now,
because I wanna, I wanna,
if I haven't completely offended you with
taking an economics take on looking for
a life partner, I wanna make sure I get
all the way to the end on that.
And this is the part of the book it's
Chapter one.
It's about search theory, but the reason
it's the last part of this talk is it's
about settling down, it's picking the
person you want to settle down with.
Now I have a girlfriend who I've now been
seeing for two and a half years.
And I can never let her go, because she's
seen me talk about this and
read chapter one of the book, and she
finds it acceptable, and
I think that the number of people for whom
that's true is a very limited set.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So the one, you know, I'm, I'm looking
for
the one that is just, that person doesn't
exist.
I hate to be the one to break it to you.
>> [LAUGH].
>> The perfect person doesn't exist.
Okay, so what you're really do,
remember I said economics is the study of
scarce resources.
So search theory, when thinking about
searching for
a partner the scarce resource is your
time.
You go on a dating site or you go to
parties.
You're using up your time.
These are.
This is.
This is very costly, it's time not spent
doing chores.
It's time not spent writing articles for
economics journals.
It's time not spent playing tennis.
It's time not spent watching Downton
Abbey.
If anybody else is a fan of Downton Abbey.
Right?
So, on the one hand, you think, "Oh,
I'm just gonna keep searching for
a partner all the time, because that's the
most important thing in my life."
. . Well, of course, it might be the most
important, but it's, it,
on the margin you substitute away from
that towards other things as well.
So people keep searching, not until they
find the one, but
until they find somebody who is good
enough God, that sounds terrible, I know.
[LAUGH] She reminds me all the time that I
said this.
She did the same thing.
Right?
I understand that so we settled, there's
a,
there's a really nice book on this by a
woman, a, a psychologist named
Lori Gottlieb who basically takes the view
that women are not good at this.
Middle a not middle aged, relatively high
income,
educated American women are not good at
this, they don't settle well enough.
And so, she has, her book is called
something like Marry Him: The Case for
Setting for Mr. Good Enough or something
like that.
So, it's not just an economics concept but
the, the underlying idea is very
economics, in terms of thinking about,
you keep searching until the costs
outweigh the benefits.
And then you say, okay, I'm gonna stop
there.
Now, that's all good.
Now, of course, this is the case I've,
I've introduced this in the most
non-romantic way possible.
And they in the market for partners, but
this is exactly the case where the job
market applies so perfectly, because what
do you do when you search for a job?
You don't search for a job 'til you find
the perfect job.
You keep searching 'til it's no longer
worth the trouble to keep trying to do
better, to try to trade up in the job
market.
Same with employees, you keep interviewing
people until you find somebody where,
you know they're not literally the perfect
person for the job, but
at some point you say, okay, the costs of
doing better would be outweighed, so
settling is the best strategy in, in both
of these contexts.
Now, this idea of settling if you will, of
is a very, was very important in 2010,
it won Dale Mortensen and Chris Pissarides
the Nobel Prize in Economics,
and one of the key points of what they
pointed put is.
That search theory,
search frictions, that is the time spent
searching, leads to unemployment.
If we're s, if we're constantly looking
for the one, we spend more,
there's time spent where, you know, we, we
are the, where we're unemployed.
Or as, as the Nobel committee said, since
the search process requires time and
resources, it created frictions in the
market.
That's the time and resources spent
looking for jobs.
On such search markets, the demands of
some buyers will not be met.
While some sellers cannot sell as much as
they would wish.
Simultaneously, there are both job
vacancies and
unemployment on the labor market.
And the exact same logic applies to
finding a life partner, and so
as I like to, as I like to say, you want
to be very careful not to be
too picky while picking, while, while on
the partner market, if you will.
Because you end up with the the equivalent
of,
of unemployment, which is loneliness, or
as I like to say, romantic unemployment.
[LAUGH].
So that's basically, you know, you gotta
at some point say, good, you know,
enough is enough and move on with your
life.
Okay, now there are many other places we
could talk about search costs.
I won't get into these now because I've
already gone over the time I
wanted to use on this.
I will just tell you.
If anybody, if I've interested any body
in,
in following up on this, you'll learn
other exciting facts from my book.
Such as that dating sites are driven by
network effects.
Which we've already talked about a little
bit but I draw it out in more detail.
Another sad fact of life is,
we are drawn to people who look like our,
who are like ourselves, okay?
And, and this has, the reason it's a sad
fact of life as,
it's inhibits economic mobility quite a
bit.
Right?
So, in, if you, if you think of somebody
marrying somebody from a completely
different socioeconomic class, that moves
people around and mixes them better.
That doesn't happen that well in real
life, and I, the economics of that are,
are, something that's very interesting to
me and many others.
The other thing is, you can, the final
point I'll make is,
that families have economics too.
And, you know, as I like to say, dating is
really just a precursor to
grand bargains and negotiations over who's
going to take out the garbage.
[LAUGH].
So, that's, that's the main point I'm
going to leave you with.
Thank you I'm gonna, you know, I'd, I'd
love to hear any questions anybody has.
If you have any more interest in following
up,
I have a Twitter account that, at least
seven people are, are on.
[LAUGH].
And you'd,
I'd be delighted to have you be the
eighth.
So thanks very much [APPLAUSE].
>> What's your thought on, in this idea in
big markets in the interviewing
continually giving advice to when I talk
with people to tell them,
here's target company's I'm looking at,
but I'm looking for the big market which
is here's what I'm looking at.
What thoughts do you have so that they'll
have a lot of ideas to talk about,
versus the idea of a target markets, I am
giving them, you know, small ideas.
>> Yeah and I think, so one thing I left
out of the whole thick market and
the search theory thing is, beyond that,
the stuff the, operations
research guys and others are good at, is
figuring out how you make these matches.
And so, the job board of tomorrow is not
gonna be the biggest even though I
told you big is better.
And the, the dating site of tomorrow
that's gonna be successful is
not the one that's the biggest now
although they have a head start.
It's the ones that figure out how to get
you,
those people closest to you on the
boardwalk, in either market.
So, these algorithms that guys are working
on all the time in both dating sites and
job markets and so forth, those, the
people who figure out how to
write those algorithms to match people,
effectively those people will, a,
make a lot of money, and b, do the world a
lot of good.
And, as economists,
we love people who do both of those things
at the same time, right?
And so, that would be great.
So, in terms of thinking about,
what do you tell people in terms of what
markets to go after, and how to target?
That's an interesting question.
I think I'd have to think through the
details in particular context.
But right now, in this day and age, in the
job market.
For better or worse, you wanna think about
using phrases that don't get automatically
spit, spit out of these on, a lot of firms
are now reviewing resumes automatically.
You have to be very careful with some of
the stuff I briefly talked about in
statistical discrimination.
If you have any words on there that kick
you out, that's a big problem.
So, that's one thing, but that's, that's
not a very specific idea.
So I don't know, I didn't answer your
question very well.
>> I, I guess my questions was [INAUDIBLE]
>> Wait, you have to wait for a
microphone.
If you.
>> Oh.
>> If that's okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, the question I had is,
everything you were talking about is very
much online.
And I guess my question is,
when you talk with people, they're always
asking what targeted companies?
And by definition you're limiting the
conversation.
And everything you're talking about is,
talk, allow for thick market conversation.
>> Right, right.
Okay, very good point.
Sorry.
So, the, the, the thing you really want to
do, the two ideals are they
go against one another is, find the big,
thick market with a lot of companies and
then, if it's worth the trouble for you to
find just the right job,
do a lot of research, and then target,
signal, whatever term you want to use.
The few that you think are exactly the
right match for you.
And I think, I think you know, job market
strategy,
would I rather send 100 resumes
generically or ten very
targeted with a long cover letter about
why I'm a really good match to that place.
I hope the second strategy would work
better.
We'll see, you know, in the long term how
that, how that does and
doesn't work and whether the, whether the
algorithms can help make that happen more.
[UNKNOWN].
>> I just wanted to ask, there's an
economic concept that
we've seen firsthand on online dating
which is product differentiation.
They haven't really talked about, our
daughter languished unmatched until
she updated her profile to say that she
had spent her summers working on
a locked psyche ward, managing a high-end
lingerie company in London.
That she'd broken my nose and
she'd been polygraphed by a federal
government agency, all of which were true.
After that, she could not fight off the
number of people.
[LAUGH].
She had to keep big lists of the guys who
wanted to meet her.
>> That's a very eclectic and interesting
set of things your daughter has done.
[LAUGH].
I'm guessing the lingerie one
was the only one she actually needed to
put on her website.
[LAUGH].
To up the attention she was getting, I you
know I,
I don't remember hearing a lot of talk in
the men's locker room about, God I
really want to meet a woman that works in
the lock down ward of a psych hospital.
But you never know.
But anyway, the simple answer to your
question is, I'm an economist.
We have marketing guys who are much better
than I am at sort of saying how do you,
how do you take.
So, I said, here are some of, the only
idea I gave you for
setting up your profile is be careful what
you don't say.
But also be really careful what you do
say, obviously.
So, you need you know, your,
your daughter did exactly the right thing,
I might add in that.
When setting up a dating profile or a
resume, this is so
ob, this is very obvious.
Have people look at it.
Yeah?
Have people look at it and say, yeah
that's kind of boring,
I happen to know you did these other
interesting things, you should add that.
Now from the, going back to my economist
view.
Have them look at it and
say, what are you thinking is true about
me that I haven't said here?
So for example, I di, I was on a radio
show, the Freakonomics podcast.
And we went through, this sounds really
cheesy, but it wasn't that bad.
[LAUGH] We went through this guy's
profile, and
I gave him advice on how to do his
profile, and he kept saying,
he kept talking about how much fun he was
and how much he liked to party.
But he was getting to a certain age where
women were looking to settle down and
of course, that was the assumption, the
underlying assumption that
people would make there is, you're not
ready to settle down.
That type of thing, which, you know, is
so, seems obvious, but
when you're, not objective about it, you,
you forget about it.
So advice number one, from both the
marketing side and the economist side is,
have someone else help you with both your
resume and your online dating profile.
>> [INAUDIBLE] The last question.
>> > That's the last question.
Okay, well thank you so much again, I
really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]